good morning Millennials welcome
back to the morning toast happy Tuesday
hope everyone's having a great Tuesday
hey Jax how you doing I'm darn good a
couple things off the bat one you really
put your foot in that GMM this morning
yeah and then also I heard you in my
headphones being like a little like you
almost get a little skepticism in your
in your voice
because you popped off so hard I was
just like oh okay because my GMM every
morning is the same I feel like I feel
like yours is fluctuates based on what's
going on in that mind of yours for sure
but one thing about me when it comes to
a tune I am gonna pop off so I just I
don't want you to ever be surprised
about that ever again yeah and now one
question before we start is that a
seamless I see oh my God no like get
your eyes checked girly two days in a
row this angle where my camera is where
I see why they come from the side so I
don't know what's going on Twix your
legs it's how sad for you
and it looks like a gorgeous little
seamless it's my favorite set from
Amazon oh my god wow it's really nice
it's really not a dress yesterday I
could understand Romper dress you don't
see the little thing between my thighs
today I'm wearing a full blouse and
shorts oh okay well you look gorgeous as
usual thank you you look stunning thank
you thank you doing my best you know
Mama Tings
Mama Tings it's been a big morning I
have such a busy day filled with content
Galore speaking of content Galore I
recorded a patreon episode yesterday
it's a vlog it's up already it is long
overdue but is all of my favorite baby
nursery Mama Tings you know our favorite
onesies our favorite gear our favorite
pacifiers our favorite gifts gifts
suggestions if you're just you know not
interested in baby things for yourself
but maybe you know someone that you know
is so it's a really great Vlog it's
honestly it's over 30 minutes of me just
like talking about the best items that
I've and I've been through so much trial
and error over the last six months that
I feel really good about sharing my Rex
plus he has links to everything so it's
there's just like sneak peeks of your
house and roll's voice
yes whoever
rolled how did you know
yeah so it's really I've been meaning to
do it for a while I'm so glad that it's
out there because I do I get a lot of
questions about my favorite baby
products and the thing is and I went on
like a whole tirade about this and I but
I can't not say this like there are so
many products out there there's so much
almost too much information it's not
like there aren't enough places that
explain what's what but it's like I
don't have time to read a Magilla about
like different stroller converters so I
found so many of the processes for
picking out some of the bigger equipment
to be so overwhelming but now that I've
chosen you know I got what I wanted and
it's the one I got because it's the one
you got I'm really happy to share you
know what actually was good for us and
what's really not
um just like tangent kind of I want to
really talk about
um rolled hmm in
I want to talk about subject the
nickname that I just want like full
credit like I fully came up with it
right well actually I'm gonna even I'm
kidding in our family like with certain
things we all do like years later we're
like well how do we get into Casey
Musgraves and literally nobody in this
family will acknowledge that it was me
literally nobody but it's fine it was me
um and so now that it's like you know
only six months like I feel like we're
gonna be calling him rolled for a while
and I just want to put it out there
everyone listening it was me
it was Claudia and that is also because
I usually come up with the nicknames
yeah but it's like I can't nickname
myself that's why I don't really have a
great name
and I think the same goes for him you
know I just call him bug and different
variations of Bugsy
tugsy is what we're calling him these
days but that's a very like affectionate
nickname like world is really
um
more of a distinguished nickname no for
sure and for anyone who might be
confused as to why his name is rolled is
because obviously his name is Harry his
you know birth name is Harrison which
honestly like I don't know Harrison like
who the [__] is Harry like obviously
when people got you gifts they put
Harrison on like a chair I'm like whose
chair is that I do not know Harrison but
he was named for our grandfather hat
rolled it's a more modern version
um but he was so much more of a Herald
when I first met him so he honestly is
such a Harold like is it too late to
change like his birth name should be
Harold I know but I just didn't want to
like send him to school with the name
Harold no for sure
but I agree with all that you're saying
and I would also say if you are
actually never mind well I was gonna say
like I feel
as though when parents are thinking of
naming their kids they're always
thinking about like Elementary School
how kids can be so mean and it's a
really good like thing to have in mind
to filter out names but there's so much
more to life than Middle School you know
I agree no I totally agree with that you
really can't get too hung up on it right
but I mean Harold is a very Antiquated
name and I just wanted like a modern
version of it and I love the name it was
always going to be Harry so it's really
not like it mattered as much but let me
tell you wow just being such a Harold
right and we also called him a lot in
the beginning Haroldson because right
right
but you know kids are unexpected because
obviously you would think okay the kid
whose name is like Gaylord would get you
know nicknamed and all these things but
kids like you can't predict like Ben has
the most regular name Ben Soffer
you know the kids used like they came up
with a nickname for that Ben soccer
he was like oh it's soccer like and it
honestly burned it plagued Ben like when
we talk about it I could tell there's
some deep trauma there that's so and he
just has a regular ass name like yeah
you really can't you can't predict
what's gonna get kids like made fun of
yeah all of these things go into naming
a person but there's not like you
shouldn't do it just because of like
middle school and every show with the
best name for for the man but calling
him Harold did lead to us calling him
which also is World dini which is a
personal favorite of mine a real dinner
he thinks I'm crazy but um he like loves
the chaos no he loves it that's the sort
of energy he just wants entertainment
and there's literally no one more
entertaining than you
I don't remember that also I'm just only
saying this because I'm literally
sinking into this couch tomorrow finally
I get my buccal chair that you have so
we'll have matching chairs this couch
I you know I definitely exceeded the
weight limit fluctuating through the
years and she's served me well but her
time has come and I'm excited
when what about when we have guests I
think you're keeping the couch no I'm
not I'm not getting rid of it I'm
definitely keeping it before your solos
Endeavors I think if you're really gonna
love this chair and if I have a guest
here and you're not here and it's just
like a one-on-one which I think we plan
on doing you know like you doing some
interviews that you want to do me doing
some interviews yeah I will be using
your chair because mine like is broken
the chair that you used to sit in is not
nearly as sunk in as mine got it okay I
love that for you uh yeah I'm excited
because we are now that we're separated
like you'll do some in-person interviews
just like you did with tpg that I can't
be there for and if we're ever doing
remote interviews like we're kind of
gonna start doing them solo which is
something that I've been like itching to
do for a while yeah because whenever
anyone we get like a pitch one of us is
always like [__] yes and the other one's
like like I don't really care because we
really do cover a lot wide range of
interests between the two of us so I
actually think it's probably going to be
better we've been I've been getting
asked a lot like what are you guys going
to do about guests
um and some of them if it's like a
really big interview I'm sure you'll fly
up yeah but for you know the regular
ones I actually think it's going to be
better it's easier to do a one-on-one
interview and there's always one of us
who's more interested in it than the
other yeah no I'm so into it me too I'll
see how it goes I think this is a good
call by us yeah we shall see new era you
guys new era
um so yes we have a new patreon I'm also
on tour girl with no job.com tour
excited to be in the Pacific Northwest
in a few weekends oh you know what I
have a dilemma because I have a an
appointment with Dr geezy today
I'm jealous I know but obviously I only
go like maybe once or twice a year for
like a little lip filler and some Botox
but I really like shouldn't be getting
Botox while I'm on tour especially
because I'm gonna film a special at one
of these remaining shows and so much of
my comedies like physical like my like I
need to be able to move my face I think
I have to say no to Botox yeah just say
no because you probably still have some
left over it's not like you're like me
just raw dogging it through life right
now and you I think better air on the
side of caution plus like you have a
young sprightly gorgeous botch and you
don't want to like do a special and it's
like girl can't move her face and it's
all anyone's talking about no I know but
it's like okay I'm recording a special I
want to look my best what do I do Botox
but I honestly feel like hard impacts
the company right right it would impact
the comedy it would impact the comedy no
you have to say no but what about lip
filler you know I love when you get lip
filler oh no I'm definitely open to it
even though I have to I have to sit down
with her have her take a look she's
really good about not making me look
crazy
um and the last time I did it which I
don't know how long ago it was she gave
me a new type of formula that lasts way
longer and I still might have it in my
lips and if that's the case then I don't
think I should be getting more because I
really am very conscious of not looking
nuts you definitely have something in
your lips because you don't look like oh
yeah the girl that you used to look like
and thank God for that because I'm about
to destroy my phone with the app Timehop
I really
um I just cannot believe how many years
I walked around looking the way that I
did like with no regard for my face my
looks my clothing my body it's really
it's astonishing like the morning breath
was probably the ugliest year of my life
which is so crazy because it was such a
great year for me personally
professionally like I got married that
year this is 2017.
um and I just feel like it really goes
to show like what you look like really
doesn't matter you know even though now
in hindsight I'm like but I was having
all this wonderful success in my
personal life we got this brand new show
like all these great things were
happening for me even though I was like
an ugly B
yeah and I think that's the takeaway
honestly I'm just trying to be positive
I think that's a really good lesson but
you know what I've realized recently I
feel like up until recently I would look
back at old photos like where I was
beastly and be like you're a beast
Miranda beastly yeah but now maybe it's
because like I'm a mom or maybe just
because I'm a beast now I look back at
even though be the former beastly
moments and I'm just like you're so cute
you know I know like you have like a
protectiveness over your younger self
like yeah I don't know I think that's
which I don't know which
which one it is if it's just because I'm
bigger than now than all those times
where I thought I was big or if it's
just because like I have Mama eyes and
it's like you're a sweet young thing
stop being so hard on yourself no I
think becoming a mom like definitely
makes you realize like you know the
woman you look back at those pictures
you can't hate that woman because that
woman is a part of rolled being here
today you know what I mean like it's all
meant to happen you were meant to be in
the place you know
yeah yeah no and I just think like if
you're not looking back on old photos
and wanting to die immediately like
you're not living the true Human
Experience no and you're not growing
you're not that would mean that you look
the same then as right now and it's like
so we've learned nothing we're learning
nothing and I just think we're not
learning how to you know fill in our
eyebrows in a way that we do like that's
not too much
but that is enough I feel like there
might be someone out there who's
contemplating you know whether or not to
get them all removed and this might be
the sign that you need to get them all
removed like you won't regret it and
it'll change your life
yeah or that's pretty much for me that's
pretty much always the takeaway yeah or
Botox or fillers yeah like if you want
you're on the fence we've only had
positive experiences but you know what I
actually know some people who have not
so Kim she was allergic remember right
or just the good thing about it is that
it is all temperatures if you don't like
how it is for you you don't have to do
it again but um
I love it and I miss it and I'll be back
soon
this is not to say like everyone needs
to get plastic surgery I just think that
at all normalize disliking things about
yourself and not just having to accept
them you know like you can change things
like and if it'll make you feel better
inside and you're doing it for yourself
like do it yes but also normalize like
nobody's perfect love yourself the way
of course it's such a hard line to walk
where it's like normalized normalize
self-improvement and self-acceptance oh
Jackie what that that's it because I
strongly believe like in just loving who
you are like the person that you were
born but then I'm also like the second
something arises about my body or my
face or anything that I don't like
removing it immediately you know yeah
it's just like
most things in life it's somewhere in
the middle layered
layered it's a little bit of both not
everything is all one thing not
everything is all one thing
yeah I think that's a great lesson to
get into today's episode I agree
so without further Ado
it is time where are you where are the
boys Theo's just busy as [__] like
honestly no time for Auntie no time for
Mom building his Empire going on walks
being sexy it's it's a tough life also
what's going on with the doggy crew now
that Bryce is gone like is it the same
are they completely born completely
disbanded I have not seen mystery I have
not seen Butters I have not seen a
single member of the gang since Bryce's
departure
he was the glue he was the glue
literally Bryce is Rascal Flatts Me And
My Gang we live to walk we walk to live
okay wow I mean I wasn't expecting that
this morning but Bryce will be happy to
know that he doesn't have to have fomo
nothing's going on without him right now
without further do here are the fast
side stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
did we hit the crunch apparently
yesterday we hit it yesterday too oh
there was rumors starting there was a
lot of rumors outside of room is
starting I'm sick of being we hit the
crunch on our soundboard yesterday and I
never thought to like
check on before I uploaded the audio
that like it was there because it's
always there but it wasn't there so I'll
double check today oh okay oh I thought
that
we always hit it got it the soundboard
here at HQ I'm sorry so the people who
said that it wasn't there like they
weren't lying no no no got it I thought
for a second when you were like we hit
it I was like where are these rumors
coming from no we physically hid it but
I don't believe it made it to the final
cut it might be because of the new way
yeah yeah but I can always add it in in
post so I'm glad we know about this now
obviously you know remote Tings always
in flux always getting better I mean my
chair arrives tomorrow after tomorrow's
episode which is so annoying but
um constantly evolving constantly
shifting working on it constantly love
it okay now let's get into
I'm ready okay today's episode is
brought to you by Ink Master Ink Master
returns September 7th with a new season
and a new home on Paramount plus beloved
legendary artists returned to shop the
returned to the shop to battle it out
facing some of the most exciting and
epic challenges seen in the history of
the competition all for the biggest
grand prize yet 250 000 and the champion
title of Ink Master in the new season
Joel Madden heart eyes is joined by
judges Nico Hurtado Ami James and Ryan
Ashley and guest star Dave Navarro as
the master of chaos witness some of the
most memorable flash challenges in the
show's history amped to extreme even
seemingly impossible
levels Unforgettable elimination tattoos
that challenge previous artists will be
twisted in a new way that'll Force
competitors to push their skills to the
limit in an ultimate battle like no
season before just when you think the
competition has been narrowed to the
best of the best the race to the title
will be elevated to a never-before-seen
level when four crowned Ink Masters
enter the competition Legends will
battle it out to prove that they are the
masters of not only the basics but of
all the high level skills that set an
ink master apart composition Precision
color theory finesse stamina endurance
the new season of Ink Masters is
streaming September 7th exclusively on
Paramount plus head to paramountplus.com
to try it for free today's episode is
also brought to you by stamps.com if
you're a small business owner you know
how important it is to be ready for the
insane holiday season it is already that
time y'all like don't get it twisted
don't let it just
Flash in front of your eyes if you
haven't started preparing for the chaos
of the holiday mailing and shipping
you're already falling behind stamps.com
has everything you need luckily to make
your life a whole lot easier it's the 24
7 post office that you can access from
anywhere there's no lines no traffic and
absolutely no hassle stamps.com is your
One Stop Shop for all of your shipping
and mailing needs you can get access to
USPS and UPS Services anything you need
to run your business right from your
computer with inflation On The Rise
every dollar counts so protect your
margins with major discounts on USPS and
UPS rates get ahead of the holiday chaos
this year get started with stamps.com
today sign up with promo code toast for
a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
free digital scale there's no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com Click the microphone at the
top of the page and enter code toast
great thank you you're welcome
our first story a little lovely news
Jennifer Lopez serenaded Ben Affleck at
their Georgia wedding with a new song
pass the mic the bride is ready to sing
in a video obtained by TMZ JLo is shown
singing and never before heard song for
her new husband Ben Affleck at their
Georgia wedding celebrations last
weekend in the clip the actress and
singer croons directly to Affleck who
was seated in a chair directly across
from her smiling and enjoying the
performance before holding the mic out
to the crowd to have them join in on the
catchy refrain which was Can't Get
Enough the lyrics go all night I can
feel the passion in your eyes I'm still
in love with you she's saying as she was
surrounded by backup dancers now before
I get your thoughts on all of this I
just want you also to know that JLo has
slammed this leaked video of her
serenading Ben at the wedding right it
wasn't a JLo approved video that they
put out on
no it didn't come out through the
newsletter it was taken by a guest and
then and leaked and sold to TMZ so she
commented on an Instagram video saying
this was taken without permission period
and whoever did it took advantage of our
private moment I don't know where you
all are getting it from because we had
ndas and asked everyone to not share
anything from our wedding that is our
choice to share anything I put out is
private on the JLo and to share with my
fans which I will do when I'm ready to
this was stolen without our consent and
sold for money thank you for caring I
love you guys okay so it sounds like
she's more upset that she didn't get the
exclusive or on the jlo.com than she is
about the fact that it's a huge invasion
of privacy and I do agree with her like
that she should be mad if the point of
having like a really small low-key
wedding like that when you're a
celebrity is that [__] doesn't get
leaked and so that means that either you
know someone they invited friends and
family leaked it or someone who was
working at the event because those only
people who would be inside
yeah and that's [__] up it is [__]
up I feel like someone who was a guest
I'm sure guests could take pictures and
videos but just like not share anything
maybe someone like took a video and then
like went home and they're like kids saw
it on their phone and like send it to
themselves and then you know sold I mean
you're being really optimistic I just
don't think one of her 100 close
personal friends who like got the invite
is selling like that would be so it's
[__] up yeah it really it's a betrayal
but that doesn't sound like the reason
as to why she's upset over it like she's
missing out on the engagement the likes
yeah and the subscribers and you're
doing it all for on the JLo right but
let's talk about the actual contents of
the video because because you have
strong feelings on this concept I do and
I actually think I'm gonna really
surprise you so
um she's getting roasted people are like
this is so cringy
um and there's definitely an element of
cringe to it and for the most part like
I think it's really touch and go when
the bride or the groom is gonna sing or
dance like whatever their you know
Talent is I think it's more often than
not going to be weird I happen to think
that like this video was really cute I
mean she's JLo for God's sakes like why
who why get a performer to perform at
your wedding when literally JLo is the
bride and like we said a couple weeks
ago like they're extremely chewy and
this is a really chewy thing to do it's
very live laugh love I think it's really
on brand for them and I kind of found
myself like finding it really cute
actually not finding it like incredibly
cringe he was definitely cringy a little
but that's them yeah I also think what
makes it cuter is the fact that like she
didn't share that she was doing this
there was not like or maybe she was
going to but the way that we're finding
out about it is like they really
intended for it to be a private sweet
moment it wasn't like her like putting
out a new song with like the music video
from her wedding on the date like it
wasn't a whole machine maybe that was
the plan though so um you know it was
stymied but the way that we're seeing it
it seems very genuine and sweet and I
agree like JLo is getting married who
else are you gonna have at your wedding
an original song like it's very it's
cute it's cute and they're just so she's
such a romantic you know right almost in
a chewy way yeah and
I'm never gonna I'm Never Gonna Knock
that no and it wasn't like this big
stage with tons of backup singers
dancers it was literally JLo on the
Dance Floor him sitting in a chair right
in front of her and she like three
backup dancers like it was kind of
low-key and I don't know I wasn't
bothered by it but people like on the
internet were just like dying over like
the cringe factor and I do think
something like that when done at a
wedding always has a possibility to be
cringy and more often than not it does
but on this particular occasion I
actually found it cute
and I also feel like there are certain
people who when they get married like
they should be singing at their wedding
you know right like who is Andrea
Bocelli gonna you know sing down the
aisle too if not himself right you know
even I know you have harsh feelings
Michael Buble should be singing at his
own wedding the way Michael Buble's
image in my mind never recovered from
that Instagram live with his wife is so
astonishing to me because you know I
forget everything and I actually like
I've been to a Michael Buble concert at
Barclay Center with Ben like I actually
am like a big fan
um
and the way I was never able to look at
him the same I don't know whether it was
a you know a one-time thing or it was
really just you know a bad look and
that's not how he really is but I saw
something in him in that Instagram live
and if you don't know what I'm talking
about just Google it like I like do not
[__] with Michael Buble whatsoever
yeah he has a new song out though that's
really good and that's why I feel like
if he sang himself down the aisle at his
own wedding I would be like egotist
egotist like because I saw like a really
like dark side of him in that Instagram
live I know
so that's not a good example but like
let me like Adele like obviously that's
what I was gonna say yeah if Adele's
getting married she should be singing
someone like you and I definitely
um
have regrets about not singing myself
down the aisle at my wedding
um but religion not down there no I
literally said I'm a bouquet give me a
microphone
so you have regrets that I didn't sing
you down the aisle with my relation of
Camp Help Falling in Love But the thing
is we both had modern Orthodox weddings
and kolisha is a real thing so actually
you can't sing in front of a rabbi and
that's why I personally didn't sing
right that's why that was the only
reason otherwise it would have been a
no-brainer
no-brainer but I did think it was
extremely and I feel like I've said this
to you before but it's worth mentioning
again I do feel as though it was
extremely gracious and extremely
generous and really honestly I'm not
even being sarcastic is indicative of
the type of person you are like in a
positive way that you let me sing at
your wedding reception because first of
all like you know me
had to find a way to make it about
myself and like you just handed me the
opportunity right on a platter you let
me sing probably the song I'm best at
singing like my top five in my
repertoire coming home from Country
Strong and it was so meaningful but it
was also like
she gets me you know
she gets me she really gets me you know
I actually forgot in this conversation
that you sang at my wedding right not in
the ceremony in the uh reception but I
just think like that's something most I
don't think most Brides would do and by
the way you know what it reminds me of
like when Brides throw their bouquet but
instead of throwing it they go up to
like a bridesmaid and hand it over and
the bridesmaid turns around and their
boyfriend is on one knee which is like
[__] psychotic oh my God I just got
chills I didn't know that's what people
do oh my God so it's like a trend you
know videos from weddings always go
viral on the internet and there's this
thing where like at the end of one
girl's wedding she'll toss the bouquet
and it's like oh the next girl's gonna
get married let's see but instead of
tossing it she just walks right over to
like her maid of honor and gives a turn
the maid of honor is like what and then
they turn her around and the maid of
Honor's boyfriend is on one knee so it's
like the official and people in the
comments like people on the internet
think it's [__] psychotic like this
is your day you paid so much money these
are your friends and family and like
you're gonna let some other girl make it
about herself honestly
all the brides who have done that are
bigger women than me I could never
yeah I would never um I would never be
either of the people in those that
situation but I had never heard of this
and I actually think if not overdone and
in the right circumstance and at the
right time in the wedding like later at
last call yeah I think it's cute yeah
but it's giving Sheena and Brock like
using someone else's wedding budget for
your engagement budget like I don't like
it it's tacky yes but like if it's your
maid of honor and it's you know Sheena
and Brock it's like these people are
co-workers and we know that they're
close friends but it's like you're
glimming onto James and Markell like
what where's your family where's your
friends like if it was someone who's
like their family friends are there this
girl you know she's all dressed up for
the wedding like it's it's kind of if
it's the bride's sister
if yeah if it's like you speaking of
Sheena and Brock there's been a lot of
footage coming out at their wedding and
it was beautiful like really really
gorgeous I know I was telling you that
Dream Hotel in Mexico great advertising
because they did a bang-up job yeah did
you see their first dance yeah it was
really cute
I wonder if sheena's saying at this
wedding
oh good as gold I hope so because we're
good as gold I gotta add that to my
playlist
yeah so JLo saying herself not down the
aisle there's a difference between down
the aisle and performing at your wedding
for your bands um and we approve this we
approve we do shocking shockingly yeah
great
I'm glad that we fleshed that out me too
I feel good
are you ready for our next story yep
Demi Lovato regrets making her
documentaries she says that she should
waited yep Demi Lovato won't be gracing
the small screen anytime soon the singer
who uses she they pronouns revealed in
an interview with alternative press I
like how page six put that in there so
they didn't get like hate for using the
wrong pronouns because Demi recently
went and changed her pronouns from they
them to she they so she prefers she
doesn't care like if you're gonna do she
or they so like to ward off any backlash
they put that sentence in there yeah I
am she doesn't plan on making any more
documentaries about her life quote
honestly I'm really sick of watching
myself and I think other people are too
and if they aren't they can watch my
music videos over the past decade she
has released three different
documentaries outlining her struggles
with addiction and its impact on her
career quote I wish I would have waited
until I had my [__] figured out more
because now it's cemented sobriety is
what works for me and nothing else her
most recent recent documentary Demi
Lovato dancing with the devil detailed
her near your fatal drug overdose in
2018 following the incident she revealed
that she was California sober meaning
she still smoked weed and drank alcohol
in moderation however a year later she
gave up substances completely and went
into treatment however her disliker
documentaries doesn't mean she wants to
share stop her sharing her story with
fans she's just planning on waiting
until she's figured out what she wants
she said quote my story is not done so I
want to be able to say by the time I've
written a book okay this is me grown up
yeah I mean I agree with her
point but I think
her saying you know I think people are
sick of hearing for me I don't think
that's why she needs to stop making
documentaries I don't and I don't think
we're sick of her documentaries no I
think
right that's not that's not it it just
seems really confusing and inauthentic
for every couple of years to release a
documentary and be like forget what I
said in the previous one this is how I
feel and this is who I am so it's like
what do we watch the other one for
yeah I agree I think that
documentaries are often like Memoirs
where
it's like
figure out what exactly that you want to
say that like even though you will
continue to grow and change over the
years that you will not negate what you
said in all of that but just like that
was your truth up until that point so I
feel like
with her documentaries
in them she wasn't always completely
honest with herself and therefore honest
with us right they no longer are
relevant and not even the California
sober thing but I feel like even her
first documentary she was talking about
you know her struggles as if they were
over but right then we find out in the
next documentary that she was like
between takes engaging in some of the
behavior that she was talking about as
if it was in the past so there's no
pressure for anyone especially people
who are struggling to do these
documentaries like
we will hear from you when you're good
and ready and like if that's when you're
50 years old like then there will still
be your audience is there like
don't be doing these things for us when
you need to heal first and I think it's
just become really trendy to do
celebrity documentaries no matter how
long you've been famous for or no matter
how old you are and I do feel like
documentaries should be reserved for you
know and when it comes to celebrities
people who have been in the business a
really really long time
um like I think one of the better
documentaries I've seen recently was the
Shania Twain one and it's like it was
her journey at a glance her career is
not over but what she had to say like
now was the time and it's like Taylor
Swift's first documentary was like
literally 15 years after she got famous
like I think you need to wait a certain
amount of time like I think and I always
use this example like I think Shawn
Mendes's documentary was one of the
worst pieces of content I've ever seen
in my life I was just about to say like
Shawn Mendes doesn't need a documentary
no it had only been like six years since
he got famous from Vine and it was just
it was not good and the whole
documentary about Camilla when they
literally broke up six months later so
then it invalidates it's like oh
irrelevant care yeah I feel like there's
a lot of pressure for that's not to say
though that your life can't change as a
celebrity after you release a
documentary that's not what I'm saying
no I don't think that's what you were
saying I think there's a lot of pressure
for people to do documentaries I think
there's a lot of interest in
documentaries on all different subjects
and these streaming services are
constantly looking for Content yeah just
like giving out documentaries but one I
think a lot of times they're premature
and two I think it could be really
invasive for people who are not ready
but like who's going to turn down an
opportunity to share not even the money
but like someone comes to you and says
like and especially if someone you know
a celebrity who's maybe struggling with
something and wanting to share and it's
a really good medium to tell your story
but it's not always the right time so I
think it can be really attractive to do
a documentary because you feel like it's
the perfect Forum to talk about what
you're going through but I think it also
puts a lot of pressure on you to be
healed and have it all figured out right
and then you don't okay so premature is
the perfect word to use for it also I
think another really good example of
someone who waited an extremely long
time is Paris Hilton's documentary that
was on YouTube recently one it totally
changed how I think a lot of people saw
her I think they ended up having a lot
of respect for her hustle and her
business Acumen and her brain and you
know she's in her 40s now we've known
her since she was 17. I think it was a
really good documentary and the time was
right
yeah
yeah I'm just like thinking about
documentaries in general or if the
documentary is going to document you
know a milestone Halftime by JLo five
foot two Lady Gaga both of those
documentaries were like here's the
process this isn't my whole life story
and this isn't my E True Hollywood Story
because the story is not even close this
is the six months I spent preparing for
the Super Bowl also Katy Perry that was
a good one because it wasn't you know
here's who I am and what I know here is
you know me being on a historically
large tour you know being the first
woman to do so many things and you know
at the same time my personal life like
it was a moment in time not like this is
who I am
I also think with Demi
this feeling of like she's constantly
acting as if like the story's over it's
not just in the documentaries like it's
in her music it's in her interviews it's
in her song lyrics it's everything and
that's something that I feel like maybe
she feels the need like she has to
constantly be saying like Okay now I
have it figured out but she needs to
release herself from that and it does
it's not just the documentaries I
totally agree like her overall Vibe and
it's been Miley and Miley too that's
what I was gonna say but Miley's is less
serious in the sense that like I think
mileage of struggles identity wise when
it comes to her music not who she is as
a person like I think Miley probably has
a strong sense of self but when it comes
to her music it's like every couple of
years she'll go to a different genre and
be like this is what I've always wanted
to do it's like well you said that last
time yeah even though I do feel like the
rock era she recently entered into is
actually the genre she and that's
actually just indicative of her talent
because when she released Malibu in that
whole album I'm like this is the real
Miley yeah because she's really good at
what she does
no matter the genre
I agree and then and now I wonder if
like there's a correlation between them
being childcare and not just Disney but
just child stars and like
having to one like figure themselves out
in the spotlight and then having to
constantly prove that I figured myself
out yeah um and just you know like
that's what most people go through
privately but I think a lot of people
arrive maybe at that conclusion sooner
because they don't have all these
external factors yes and you know kids
who get famous really young are a lot of
the times stunted at the age that they
got famous at so perhaps you know Demi
Lovato who I think is almost 30 is
having these you know Revelations when
other people her age had them maybe 10
years ago yeah
so no more documentaries from Demi for
now I think that's probably you know for
the best for everyone yeah
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that's brought to you by
the Clinique Even Better clinical dark
spot interrupter
yes it is what a coincidence
we're so simpatico
if you have dark spots it can often feel
like a vicious cycle as soon as one
Fades another pops up break the cycle
with the Clinique Even Better clinical
dark spot interrupter this powerful
serum works on melanin Rich to fair skin
and it helps visibly correct dark spots
such as acne marks while protecting from
future discoloration so 94 of people
demonstrated an improvement in Radiance
and visible skin tone including acne
marks in just eight weeks you can see a
39 visible reduction in dark spots in up
to 12 weeks
so
um if you're looking for skin care that
targets dark spots and you've struggled
with dark spots you know how annoying
they are and how difficult they are to
get rid of and also prevent and Clinique
is a brand that you can trust I'm sure
you guys have used their products I've
used Clinique for a while I happen to
love their Foundation
um so they make really good beauty
products great skin products and they're
a brand that you can trust and I'm
someone who struggles with dark spots
and I love the Clinique Even Better Dark
Spot interrupter it's free of oil
denaturated alcohol sulfates parabens
flatulates fragrance it's also oil free
it's non-acnegenic and it's fast
absorbing absorbing and it is
dermatologist developed so you know that
the right hands were involved you can
get the even better clinical dark spot
interrupter today uh it's available at
clinique.com Clinique is spelled
c-l-i-n-i-q-u-e clinic.com for the even
better clinical dark spot interrupter
great thank you you're welcome Dory
Irina Shake poses with ex Bradley Cooper
on a tropical vacation getaway in a rare
Instagram photo
Irina shake and ex Bradley Cooper are
having fun in the sun on Sunday the
supermodel uploaded a post on Instagram
featuring various photographs of herself
on the tropical getaway with Bradley
Cooper some of them she can be seen
wearing a floral bikini and mesh
leggings while resting her head on the
actor's shoulder in other images she's
posing besides some pigs on a beach and
she's lying in the center of a heart
drawn in the sand now people are saying
you know this is co-parenting at its
finest they're obviously on a trip with
their daughter Leah
um but these like I'm sorry this just
looks like a romantic trip yeah I don't
think like even the best of co-parents
would go on like a trip the three of
them to a romantic Island and po no
maybe maybe the best of co-parents would
but post these pictures like they're
staring Us in the face like these are
couple pictures yeah no I definitely
think that she's enough together
what is the heart signify and it wasn't
Leah the kid drawing the heart so no and
it's like if they were romantically
involved at all she wouldn't post this
Carousel yeah unless like she's trying
to make it seem like they are but
I don't know her I just don't think that
she would I think that they're telling
us that they're together and why is
everyone like oh here's a romantic
picture of the two of them on a romantic
vacation it's like co-parents yeah like
what it what aren't people seeing I
agree I think this is pretty much like a
confirmation that they're back together
and you know since they have a kid
together like I love that you know I
think that's you know
kit children of divorce's dream you know
like Mommy and Daddy are getting back
together it's wonderful but just as you
know like a celebrity obsessed girly I
do not ship these two like whatsoever I
think they're hella toxic
I didn't really ship them either but I'm
shipping these photos and and if they
really you know did separate and come
back together like I love that story for
them so I'm shipping from here on out
yeah the vibe that I've always gotten
from these two I know Wimbledon we know
I actually was not going to say
Wimbledon really but those pictures of
them from Wimbledon are one of my
favorite things about this job like just
the fact that I get to talk about that
if you don't know what I'm talking about
Google it relatable the vibe that I've
always gotten from their relationship
was that she was like so much more into
him than he was into her
um and I think that's like really not
a you know if it's true I don't think
that's a like a sign of a healthy
relationship and if anybody in a
relationship is gonna like the other
more in a hetero relationship like it
has to be the man sorry in order for
things to work yes okay so with that
looking at these pictures again it could
be more of what you're saying where it's
like first of all in the picture of the
two of them like if I'm just looking at
body language like his arms are just
like down I feel like yeah and also he's
been rumored to be seeing Huma abedin so
if like he has a girlfriend oh right if
he is a girlfriend and like he knows
irena's like I'm gonna try and like make
it seem like something like his arms are
down he's kind of stiff yeah because he
was like giving water to the pigs I also
feel like he doesn't like photos do you
know what I mean no but like now through
the lens of like she likes him more like
she's trying to look like yeah we're
together and by the way I have no proof
of that it's just a vibe that I've
always felt and it was really
highlighted with the Lady Gaga stuff
um because she just looked honestly like
pathetic they made her look dumb and if
I were her I would never [__] forgive
him for that yeah they did they made her
look stupid at the Oscars like his date
he's Googling eyed you know Lady Gaga
giving her a hug and a kiss and she's
just sitting there
um so that's just always how I felt like
she is so desperate to be in a
relationship with him and he like
couldn't be bothered to give a [__] and
I have no proof of that like that's just
the vibe that I get yeah well through
that lens these pictures tell a
different story and who Dro who drew the
heart Irina who took the picture
she brought her tripod so that's just
how I feel so I'm not like dying for
these two to get back together I will
say though I was appreciative to Irena
because I don't feel like we get very
like many candid shots of Bradley Cooper
He's like very private and we certainly
don't get shirtless ones and he looks so
hot he does and he is just like Beyond
handsome and the other day I actually
went on a Bradley Cooper totally random
I saw a clip on Tick Tock you know I'm
always seeing like them show oh
I'm so annoyed
but I just remembered something
what and okay I could not sleep last
night because right before bed
I so what I was going to say before that
reminded me is I'm always ending up on
Tick Tock where like they'll show you a
random movie and like they'll explain to
you the whole plot in like 60 seconds
and it makes you want to see the movie
even though you already know what
happened and so I saw one from American
Sniper and that sent me on a rabbit hole
just like Googling pictures of Bradley
Cooper when he was you know dressed up
and in character as Chris Kyle because
he was so [__] hot and ripped so
[__] hot but yesterday before bed I
saw
a clip 60 seconds and I couldn't peel my
eyes away once I had seen it and I've
always heard always heard about the
human centipede and people are like it's
so disgusting like don't ever look it up
and I never looked it up what is that
and if I had it's a movie and if I had
to have guessed what it was it was I
thought like they were you know taking
people and like removing their limbs and
like sewing them to other people and
they create like a chain of humans
because I knew it was a chain of humans
yeah but I thought it's just like people
wrapping their arms around each other
but I didn't even know it's a movie but
if you said a human centipede I would
think it was like 100 people just
holding each other right it's just a
connection it's like a long chain of
people being connected and I thought
people were like it's so gross I'm like
oh I'm sure they were like stapling body
parts that's really what I thought Human
Centipede was and I never bothered to
look into it
I've never thought about it what I found
out that the human centipede was last
night
please don't I'm not going to say don't
tell me I'm not and if you don't know
what it is like I really encourage you
like this is not something you want to
be curious about like it will ruin your
life oh my God I couldn't sleep I'm
gonna vomit it was a movie is this a
real thing I don't know the backstory I
just know it's a movie you want me to
look at it's just like a gory movie with
a gory concept it's not gory it's so
disgusting it's very similar in a sense
to the feeling that you get from Black
Mirror Pig prime minister episode
okay
okay so it's a it's a disturbing movie
Disturbing disturbing plot about this
Warden of a prison who does something so
disturbing to all the prisoners is
Bradley Cooper in it no but I saw a clip
on Tick Tock from the same account that
I saw the American Sniper one on and
it's just in it I don't know it's not
about who's in it you know
yeah and I don't know if the human
centipede was like a concept biblically
that turned into a movie I don't know
what the origins is but I know there's a
movie and I know there's a thing like
the human centipede I don't know where
it comes from but I finally found out
what it was
okay
I have no desire to know no Jackie
protect your heart
do not and if you're watching on YouTube
do not write it in the comments like for
real like if you don't know what it is
protect other people
I hope nobody ever has to find out what
it was I wish I I wish it was what I
thought it was which was just like you
know murderers like putting
shoulders on butt cheeks I don't know
okay I never thought about this honestly
I don't even I'm so sorry to have
changed the tone I just forgot that I
was literally it was a night full of
Terror for me
okay
okay let's just move on so do you think
Irina shake and Bradley Cooper are back
together
after everything we've discussed
no
me neither anymore now I know why
everyone's just like go parents right no
I don't think so those arms tell a
different story yeah the body language
and I think that if they actually were
romantically involved Bradley wouldn't
want that [__] posted he's never been
public about his life but you know
showing the World Health and
co-parenting that's probably something
he wouldn't mind posting and if irvina
is not his girlfriend like he can't tell
her what to post not even if she was his
girlfriend that she could he could tell
her what to post but she would want to
be mindful of what he wants because
you're in a relationship and you don't
want to start a fight 100 what you just
said 100 percent
Irena went rogue Irena went rogue iroga
okay I'm glad we got to the bottom of
that they're not back together
ships
back to Port back to Port I did that I
already dated so who Suki Waterhouse oh
yeah like if I could come back in this
life as anyone it would be Suki
Waterhouse so I could date Bradley
Cooper and Robert Pattinson
yeah and you'd be in some really good
movies too what is she in
she's in like everything she was in
something we just watched that Woody
Allen movie she was in rainy day in New
York yeah she was the girlfriend who
comes back she's always like the
girlfriend who's out of town who comes
back and so it's like she only has to do
like one day on set she's in the credits
she's at the film festival she's on the
red carpet yeah you know totally who's
your girlfriend in the movie I don't
even remember remember when Elle Fanning
is with that director
yes yes
and then he like shoves her out the door
she's also in she's in something that we
love sorry I'm just
I'm going to her IMDb she's just one of
those girls who I feel like was born
under a lucky star again I know nothing
about her or her life just that's the
way it seems like she literally like
released a song even though I don't
think she has any experience and like
the song went so viral on Tick Tock like
the type of virality artists only dream
of the skyline Falls and I try to make
sense of it all yeah
if you guys like know that song from
Tick Tock you would die if you found out
if you didn't know she's the Suki
Waterhouse sings it she's gonna be in
Daisy Jones in the six which I know you
didn't love the book but there's a
series coming out of it and now that
we're Elvis girlies Elvis's
granddaughter is playing daisy Jones
Riley Keough which I knew that when the
news broke but now I didn't have like a
care so much about it so Elvis's
granddaughter Lisa Marie had a baby with
who
um she's had I think she's has four kids
that are half siblings
and Riley Keough I don't know who
Riley's father is
very interest on and tsuki Waterhouse is
playing Karen who I think is the the
female drummer in the band oh yeah she
was honestly
um she was cool I like the drummer
Loki you know I think it will be a very
good TV show it was a I liked the book I
think so too I do hate it I did not like
the book and there were a lot of people
who agreed with me and a lot of people
said that the audiobook was amazing so I
think you know Book audiobook TV show
like it might be the type of story that
needs to be told visually if it's so
much better audibly with different
people it was like a play I heard the
audiobook was yes okay our next story
Chris Rock says he was asked to host the
2023 Oscars and his response would a no
Chris Rock returning to the 2023 Oscars
would be like returning to the scene of
a crime the comedian told a phoenix
comedy show audience on Sunday that he
was asked to emcee next year's event but
declined the opportunity according to
the Arizona Republic the star told the
crowd that going back to the Oscars
would be like asking Nicole Brown
Simpson to go back to the restaurant
where she left her eyeglasses before she
was killed in a reference to the murder
trial of OJ Simpson who was acquitted in
the case he rejected hosting duties his
rejected hosting duties would have come
a year after Will Smith slapped him at
the Academy Awards okay that Nicole
Brown Joe was like hella unnecessary
very unnecessary like it's a joke so by
the way
do you know that the Nicole Brown when
she left her sunglasses at the
restaurant and then Ron Goldman came you
know the restaurant was Craig's
no I feel yeah it was and I feel like
everyone knows that but they don't
really put together that it's also like
currently still celeb Hot Spot Craigs
God I think I've got a restaurant like
that like it wouldn't survive a scandal
like that they didn't do anything no I
know but I should suffer totally a local
business
yeah
um yeah I don't think it's the same as
that but it's a joke so no it's a joke
um
I don't know who thought it would be a
good idea to ask him I love that Chris
Rock said no and I don't know what his
reasonings were but mine would be like I
literally got slapped you didn't even
kick this man out uh why the [__] would
I work with you and like give you the
ratings because of course everyone would
tune in see what he said it would be
like a big moment and why the [__] would
Chris Rock do that
for the Academy when the academy like
was being just carried on with the show
and then gave him an Oscar right and let
him speak and let him and let him speak
yeah um yeah I don't think Chris Wright
feels the academy has his best interest
no I understand why they asked him like
it would be amazing and that's really
all everyone was talking about from last
year and whenever there's a moment that
everyone's talking about or even like a
host or a presenter then you know they
try and capitalize it on it for the next
year it would be great television if he
hosted the Oscars because now you can't
really talk about the Oscars without
like just thinking of the slack of Chris
Rock
the slap but yeah um decline it's also a
thankless job and right this flat
pattern happened like a lot of people
don't want to do it and you end up like
always getting like backlash or people
saying you didn't do a good job it's a
thankless [__] job it's hard work and
Chris Rock doesn't need the work like
he's literally one of the best selling
comedians of all time like he's just
fine yeah so I think it was a no on all
fronts um I wonder who will host but
it's like I don't know what the
reasoning is why Kevin Hart has never
done it since you know that whole thing
is it that he hasn't been asked or he's
just over it he was asked I think I
think he's over it and
I think he was
I don't know if pissed is the right word
but I think the piss was like taken out
of it for him and the fun was you know
for sure
it was his dream
then it became just like this whole
thing and it just
I think he moved on but you know and
another great example for a celebrity
documentary that was done well was the
Kevin Hart one it wasn't you know Kevin
Hart was born in New York it was the the
year after the Oscars thing like the
journey he went on what he learned Etc
and in the documentary he was like I'm
so sorry like it didn't seem like he was
pissed at all it seemed like he was like
groveling almost like he was so
apologetic right for something he
literally said 15 years ago
I actually never watched the documentary
so I'm still like I only know right so
in the documentary his tune completely
changed then you know when he wouldn't
apologize
when it was announced
um he was like I've apologized a million
times like I'm not gonna let this keep
following me he was very you know strong
in his stance and a year later or maybe
a year and a half later when that
documentary came out his stance was
completely different he's like I
understand why I heard people so that
kind of defiance he had
was gone and I don't know if that was
just something he was saying so that he
could move on from it press wise or if
that's how he genuinely felt but I felt
like he was already moved on like he's
the one who went back yes
so I don't know if he wants to do it or
not honestly but he would be great even
though like
I don't think it's really a job worth
getting
no I don't think so either and they can
try as they may just give it to Ricky
Gervais
he's really the only person that does a
good job
yeah and that's not to say other people
aren't talented but it's a very specific
job that not everyone is cut out for you
have to be ballsy as [__] and not a part
of like the Hollywood core like Jimmy
Fallon Jimmy Kimmel James Corden like
they're never gonna really say something
outlandish because they're a part of the
problem like they're part of like the
Hollywood Elite whereas like what the
[__] just Ricky Gervais care he lives in
London give it to Andrew Schultz right
like somebody on the total outs to
really be able to poke fun at
like the elephant in the room which is
like this is so dumb yeah yeah like
somebody a podcaster
I would love Conan they're the only ones
with the courage
a hundred percent and I'm not saying
like you were I really like no we're not
suggesting ourselves honestly I mean it
don't want it like no no I don't want it
either but I want to see some of my
favorite comedic podcasters out there
yeah roasting roasting like Tim Dylan
Tim Dylan that was my nomination last
year oh was it yeah when we had this
conversation last year and we decided it
needs to be a podcaster we were talking
like Bill Burr Tim Dylan we just watched
Andrew Schultz's special it was really
dark
it was wild it was wild honestly like it
was a wild ride it was so funny that and
you know part of the reason I was
interested in watching it was because
there was like this big scandal with him
where Netflix bought his special and
they had requested he take out so many
jokes that for the sake of his art he
didn't want to do it anymore and he
bought back his special I'm sure that
put him honestly in enormous debt so I
wanted to see like what was too crazy
for Netflix and I assumed it was too
offensive in terms of like not
politically correct enough
um to crass to you know
out there but I think
the reason why it was pulled from
Netflix which I was shocked by was it
was too dirty like it was really sexual
and that's not what I was anticipating I
was ready to hear him say some like
crazy controversial you know thoughts
there was all of that yeah
but it was also really dirty it was
sexual I don't the way that we were able
to watch it I don't because it's kind of
hard to find because it's like it's like
it's a service that you can purchase on
on a website but then like once you get
it you have to airdrop like AirPlay it
to you we airplayed it from our iPad to
a TV it's not a wasn't a premium
experience no the watching it was
premium but I feel like trying to go and
find it was hard but maybe that's just
because we're unfamiliar with the
platform but anyways it was really it
was a wild ride it was wild honestly
yeah it was fun don't watch it with like
literally anyone you respect no yeah
don't watch it with your parents no do
not watch it with your parents watch
with like your husband boyfriend
girlfriend something like that yeah or
by yourself
yeah it was funny though it was funny
but like I definitely felt like a little
awkward like your husband sat in for
like 30 minutes and I was like please
leave
well Ben was there the whole time yeah
no I know
are you ready for our fifth and final
story is it the fifth and final story
that's brought to you by honey honey
you got so honey baby
today's episode is sponsored by Honey
the easy way to save when shopping on
your iPhone or computer thanks to Honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it finds to your cart here's how it
works imagine you're shopping at one of
your favorite sites for me I buy
clothing Electronics food I buy so many
things online and honey works with so
many of the websites that I frequently
shop out so you go to check out honey
button appears all you have to do is
Click apply coupons wait a few seconds
honey will search the internet for
coupons it can find and if they find a
working one you'll just watch the price
drop it takes two seconds out of your
life it saves you a ton of money I've
saved literally thousands of dollars of
the last three or four years that I've
been using honey
and now it doesn't just work on your
desktop it also works on your iPhone
just activated on Safari and you will
save while you're on the go if you don't
already have honey you are straight up
missing out by getting it you're doing
yourself a solid we would never
recommend something we don't use and you
can get honey for free at joinhoney.com
toast that's joinhoney.com toast
our fifth and final story Little
Housewives news Lisa Rinna has archived
her post about supporting garcelle's son
she said quote it did nothing so Rina
posted to her Instagram
um a screenshot of messages with a fan
who asked why her post she had posted
the Bravo statement a lot of other
Housewives had posted it too from
different franchises right she uh
reposted it like you know in defensive
garage sales son and then she was asked
what happened to the statement on her
Instagram and this was her reply
I archived it that's all I've been
keeping my social media page very edited
if you notice I'm keeping it very
positive non-negative and fashion and
fun I don't want anything negative on my
grid and since my own children are being
threatened as we speak I felt it best to
Archive it the statement did nothing so
why keep it up our children are getting
death threats to all of our children
it's gone beyond and I need to keep my
family safe now I will no longer be
saying or posting anything about the
show
okay like I get what she's saying it
definitely has gone beyond and I'm sure
that everyone's kids are getting
harassed I don't think to the level that
garcelle's kids were getting harassed
one because garcelle's
kids like their harassment was like a
coordinated attack like by Bots like it
was really and it was like race racially
motivated it was like really bad
um I get what she's saying but
I do think deleting it or archiving it
whatever she said like
makes me think there's more to it you
know and like of course yeah things like
that do nothing that's so performative
that's literally like the basis of
social media like everything is
performative like everything you post
like it just is so I agree with that
concept but the posting and then
archiving of it makes me think it's like
there's something more nefarious going
on yeah it makes it like you know
drama-filled but what's I what's
I like I'm not caught up on the show so
I don't know like what's changed and why
all the kids are now getting death
threats when the show's been airing for
more than 10 years every other franchise
like this hasn't been an issue until
this season right and it's just making
me think of like what you theorized
the where you theorized the Bots were
coming from like what's new about this
season that's different from others
Diana yeah so um there's really not even
that much going on on Beverly Hills
right now garcelle's son especially her
younger one like was involved in a brief
storyline with Erica Erica was like
wasted and she yelled at him like get
the [__] out of here and garcelle was
like do not talk to my kids like that
right um and it wasn't really a big deal
and that was weeks ago right so I don't
know why
why this is happening when it's never
happened it does make you think there
also are a lot of people who think that
Lisa Rinna was behind the Bots but Lisa
Ren has been on this show for many years
and it's never happened so I agree like
the new Factor has to have something to
do with it and that has to but now that
you told me that theory like that's all
I can think because the fact that all
the kids are getting this they were
never in play before like this was not
ever happening and that's always been a
line that I feel like the the housewives
never crossed the fans really don't
cross it unless I mean unless the kid is
doing confessionals you know like what
about Jolie like remember when people
were messaging her like disgusting
things about her mom and it was on the
show yeah see but I also think that this
is a lesson to Housewives and reality TV
stars everywhere like it's especially
for your kids if you
if they are on public like I just think
that that's something you should rethink
I think kids are totally off limits but
you know how discussing the internet is
you know how [__] crazy Bravo fans
are to the point where like I'm actually
worried about the network and I think
that they're crazy [__] fans are
making them look really bad and having a
negative impact on like their overall
image so I would just keep that in mind
like I do think if you're going to be a
housewife like your kids social media
should be on private which makes it
tough because then you look at like Gigi
Hadid and you see what it did for her
and then you look at Delilah and Amelia
and it's like wow there's so many
opportunities and and I get it
but you have to weigh you know the pros
and the cons yeah 100 and I think that
the cons really outweigh I agree Rose it
depends like where you
what you're looking for but yeah and
it's definitely never gotten to this
level now but now that it has I think it
probably makes all the other women on
different franchises who have kids on
the show it makes them you know second
take a second and think
yeah
that's just wild it's wild and then
everyone was freaking out because Lisa
Rinna took Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills out of all of her social media out
of all of her bios thinking that she's
been fired but I feel like she pretty
much just explained why she did that in
that Instagram story she said I'm not
going to mention the show on my socials
anymore so yeah I think for I mean I
think that's kind of silly it's like
you're on the show what are you trying
to pretend like you're not on social
media for great spots like they know
that you are but I think for Rena
because she really you know she's like a
celebrity before she's a housewife and
so I think she's just trying to like
separate between like here's me Lisa
we're in as a celebrity and then like I
also I'm in this TV show it's a little
too late for that she used to be a
celebrity before she was a housewife yes
she's a little too it's a little too
late for that celebrities exclusively
housewife her followers are Bravo fans
like is she so enmeshed with that but I
think she's like trying to separate it
like even like maybe like Erica Jane and
Erica Girardi but there's nothing to
separate there's nothing to separate and
I I do think her taking it out of her
bios and stuff is very dramatic dramatic
and victim energy gonna cause people to
talk and
and don't get me wrong I would love for
her to be fired but I don't think that
that's what happened no not at all I do
think it's a possibility
but it hasn't happened no but I think
like based on this season I think that
it's a possibility that she might not
return she's very everything she does is
like kind of low budget
um
and I don't think she can keep up with
this group of women honestly I feel that
way
yeah
I have to watch to see for myself but
those reasons don't sound like fireable
it's not actually not someone fired but
like not asked to be back yeah no but no
no sorry not fired but those just seem
like personal preferences of yours oh oh
okay she's constantly bringing the drama
like constantly letting someone else
know what someone else said like she's
she's doing what she's supposed to do
yes
um
so yeah period
so yeah those were the past five stories
you definitely needed to know them yes
two days in a row of Premium stories it
feels good
it does and that is our show tomorrow we
are back um for Wednesday with dear
toasters oh and today I'm recording the
redheads with all the girls we're
recapping Everything I Know About Love
by Dolly alderton so if you're reading
along with us make sure to email your
questions about the book or just books
in general to the redheads book club
gmail.com it's going to be such a great
episode thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found on Spotify
all the places wherever you listen to
podcasts find us some more details and
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are hope
you guys have an incredible amazing
Tuesday and we'll see you tomorrow for
hump day bye bye